fatiga crónica dolores menstruales
migraña estos síntomas de la
endometriosis hacen la vida cotidiana de
yasmina especialmente difícil a sus 42
años sueña con una vida normal Esta es
mi casa la he comprado para vivir sola
pero debido a las limitaciones que me
provoca la endometriosis no no lo puedo
hacer Necesito ayuda para que me hagan
la comida muchas veces me tienen que
llevar a la cama
ella es mina le resulta imposible vivir
sin la ayuda de su madre con diagnóstico
Desde hace dos años consume una veintena
de medicamentos y complementos
alimenticios a diario curso pasado Yo
Soy maestra estuve como 10 meses de baja
y menos mal que trabajo en una escuela
pública si no hubiese perdido mi trabajo
seguro España acaba de introducir un
permiso menstrual financiado por el
estado desde el primer día del periodo
sobre dictamen a médico la ciudad de
Girona se adelantó las 600 empleadas del
ayuntamiento disponen de un permiso
menstrual Hola Esther Hola Qué tal Bien
a ver bueno a mirar los datos de cómo
llevamos el tema de la menstruación lo
han pedido así de mujeres en total en
todo el ayuntamiento
aquí las mujeres pueden ausentarse hasta
8 horas al mes a recuperar pero el
ayuntamiento no exige ningún
justificante es un éxito para aquellas
personas que realmente lo necesitan no
es un número muy elevado pero sí que es
un derecho que sabe que dispone todas
las trabajadoras este nuevo derecho es
el resultado de una batalla sindical
para este funcionario la ley nacional va
más allá y convierte a España en un país
pionero en Europa
es un avance en el Sí porque pone la
menstruación en el en Boca de la
sociedad y porque reconoce patologías
relacionadas con la menstruación en
España alrededor del 15% de las mujeres
padecen endometriosis